time for pft on yahoo sports peter king
mike florio here with some of the
biggest stories in the national football
league and the 49ers were so good last
year on their way to becoming the top
seed in the nfc and almost winning the
super bowl it was easy to think they
would just do it all over again the
problem as we see
every year for one or more teams in the
nfl the injury bug the 49ers have had as
many as 14 players on injured reserve
and two more will be headed there now
thanks to injuries that happened on
sunday to jimmy garoppolo aggravates the
high ankle sprain and george kittle
fractured bone in his foot peter my
goodness
i look an elite team dealing with this
kind of hardship and this kind of
of
just constant injury over and over again
how can they ever compete and here they
are at four and four are we at the point
where the 49ers just have to accept the
fact that it's not happening this year
uh i think so mike i mean unless they
shocked the world on thursday night
uh and beat the packers and look they
scored 37 in both games against the
packers last year neither one of them
was very competitive
you never know what can happen but
you know i was looking at this list
eight of their most important ten
players
are gone eight of them
of their most important 10 players will
not play on thursday you know you add it
not only of the guys you see on the
screen right there but westin richburg
their valuable center
uh is also gone and the thing that i
think has gotten way too little
attention
is the loss of richard sherman
and you know richard sherman to me
enters every game no matter whether he's
getting up there in years no matter
whether he's battling an injury whatever
he enters the game with a bravado like
come on aaron rodgers come at me come on
let's go
and bring it on
and they are just missing that on
defense without bosa without ford
without richard sherman with a revolving
door recently at safety
uh with jimmy ward being banged up i
just think you look at this team right
now
and i'm really worried that
this could all force john lynch and kyle
shanahan
into because i mean right now it looks
like they're not going to make the
playoffs it could force them into
decisions that they really don't want to
make
and decision number one what do you do
with jimmy garoppolo and i'll pose it to
you
mike what do you do with jimmy garoppolo
if at the end of this year you look at
his tenure in san francisco and say
well
we really don't know if he's that good
he's been hurt too much and when he's
played he's been too inconsistent
they've already fired the shot across
the bow when they took a look at tom
brady in march and were transparent
about it and i think that was
the shape up or ship out to jimmy
garoppolo you better go next level or
we're going to find someone else there's
already been some chatter that maybe
they should try to get matt ryan and
reunite him with kyle shanahan i think
their better play would be to try to get
kirk cousins and reunite cousins with
kyle shanahan but you look at all
options now that's the thing
everything's on the table the guaranteed
money is over there's two years left on
the garoppolo contract and i think yeah
they're at the moment now however this
plays out unless garoppolo comes back
late in the season they get to the
playoffs and make it at least to the
round of eight maybe the final four you
look at your options and you move on
from garoppolo if you find another
another choice another possibility that
works under your cap under your cash or
maybe you draft a guy
yeah here's the way i look at it mike i
mean i would be very very cynical right
now about bringing kirk cousins in
haven't you seen enough of kirk cousins
couldn't you be if you brought him in
and had to pay him a ridiculous amount
of money couldn't you be in the same
situation next year other than the
injury thing where you don't really know
if this is the guy if i'm kyle shanahan
i am betting on myself
and what i mean by that is i am saying
give me sam darnold give me the fourth
quarterback in this draft will take him
like number 13 overall
you know give me the guy that i can
develop and i can put my fingerprints on
myself that's what i want to do at
quarterback
with all that said i wouldn't be shocked
if shanahan puts together a game plan
that beats the packers on thursday night
every time we're ready to write off the
49ers they they find a way to make us
think that maybe they're still alive so
maybe they are still alive we'll see and
we'll see you next time for another
edition of pft on yahoo sports have a
great day
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports